I am berry lukayla I'm a teaching
professor in the physics department and
I've been here at Carnegie Mellon since
1980 well it focuses mainly on
understanding the science in science
fiction films and television shows so we
do some readings on cutting-edge science
and then look at some science fiction
film examples that relate to it and try
to critique the science fiction films
from a scientific point of view and it
was inspired by actually this book which
I'm sure you've heard of this is the
first edition and physics of Star Trek
written by Lawrence Krauss Susan Henry
was the Dean of the Mellon college of
science at the time and encouraged a lot
of the faculty to create mini courses
for MCS students to keep them interested
in science and I proposed a course on
science and science fiction and
everybody thought it was a great idea
but they suggested one of the things we
had to do was to build a warp drive as
part of the coursework which we haven't
succeeded in doing yet how does a warp
drive work you might well ask so the
idea is that the energy produced in the
matter/antimatter reaction in the warp
engines somehow distorts space and the
idea is that you compress the space in
front of the ship and expand the space
behind the ship and you end up riding
along on a wave of distorted space which
actually doesn't quite violate the limit
on speeds being no more than the speed
of light because you're you're traveling
along on this wave of distorted space
instead of really locally going faster
than the speed of light since the
students in the mini version of the
course have always been science majors
they really like to tear apart the films
from a science perspective and see
what's wrong with it
but we also do some pretty serious
calculations to show whether things are
plausible and every now and then
something comes up that is plausible but
usually not usually it's in the realm of
total fantasy